[Music]
sadly not every actor who joins the
Marvel Cinematic Universe ends up
sticking around some become unhappy with
Marvel some fall out of love with
blockbusters altogether and some become
victims of scheduling conflicts these
are the reasons some of the MCU ski
players have said farewell to that
universe a lot of fans were surprised
when Marvel Studios announced in 2010
that it wouldn't ask Incredible Hulk
star Edward Norton to reprise his role
in Avengers the company put out a press
release saying in part our decision is
definitely not one based on monetary
factors but instead rooted in the need
for an actor who embodies the creativity
and collaborative spirit of our other
talented cast members Norton's agents
called the statement offensive and claim
the studio unexpectedly cut off
negotiations Norton changed this story
over the years telling NPR in 2014 that
he chose to leave the role because he
wanted more diversity in his career
what's the problem before 2010 there was
already bad blood between Norton and
Marvel Norton signed on to the lead in
the Incredible Hulk under the condition
that he could rewrite Zack pens script
Marvel agreed and while Norton's added
scenes were filmed most were cut before
release two months before the movie's
premiere Entertainment Weekly reported
Norton was refusing to do press for the
film and the break with Marvel still
appears to be on Norton's mind in July
2018 just over a decade after incredible
Hulk's release he took a swipe at Marvel
during Comedy Central's roast of Bruce
Willis using his turn at the podium to
say I tried to be like Willis I did a
big action movie called The Incredible
Hulk you know what went wrong I wanted a
better script Tim Roth who played The
Incredible Hulk main villain Mo Blonsky
has revealed in the past that Marvel
actually considered bringing him back
for the sequel to THE AVENGERS
he told crave online they were going to
do it they were thinking in Avengers 2
or something it just kind of got swept
under the carpet I guess it isn't clear
from what Roth said whether they were
considering abomination as the main
villain or if he would have been working
with Ultron Roth has since said he isn't
confident about returning to the MCU and
considering the unlikelihood of a Hulk
sequel his doubts are understand
answering fan questions on reddit in
2017 Roth wrote I don't think Marvel
will ever use me again but it would be
fun luckily if Roth were to reprise the
role the fact that it's been so long
since he last played Blonsky would
actually help serve his character Roth
was in his late 40s when the Incredible
Hulk hit the big screen and the fact
that his character was an expert soldier
in an aging body was one of blonsky's
prime motivations for allowing himself
to be transformed into a monster
according to Terrence Howard the sole
reason he didn't get to reprise his role
as James Rhodes in Iron Man 2 and beyond
is simple money
Howard discussed his side of things in
2013 with Andy Cohen on watch what
happens live alleging that Robert Downey
jr. was partially responsible it turns
out that the person that I helped become
Iron Man took the money that was
supposed to go to me and push me out
Howard said Marvel signed him up for
three films and then when it was time to
make Iron Man 2 they demanded he'd taken
almost 90 percent pay cuts and I called
my friend that I helped get the first
job and he didn't call me back for three
months in a 2015 interview with Rolling
Stone
Howard clarified that he was cast before
Downey and that he took a 1 million
dollar pay cut to help convince Downey
to jump on board though Marvel took
issue with Howard's story during his
second appearance on watch what happens
live in 2017 the actor said fences had
been mended between him and Downey but
also that Marvel threatened him with
legal action after his public attacks on
Downey and Marvel am I gonna come back
and be war machine I think they could
have a huge franchise off of it when
Entertainment Weekly asked Chris
Hemsworth and Kevin Feige about Jane
Foster's absence in 2017 store Ragnarok
their answers focused largely on the
film's narrative Hemsworth explained
that Thor and foster had broken up and
that his character was enjoying being a
solo cowboy I hear that Jane dumps you
she didn't dump me you knew I dumped us
mutual dumping Feige added that with
Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie the filmmakers
were matching Thor with a warrior who
was quote much more his equal and in
many ways too superior but a much
earlier story suggested there was a
real-world reason for the breakup
according to a report from thr bad blood
started blowing between Portman and
Marvell as early as 2011 over the firing
of director patty Jenkins from for the
dark world the reports citing unnamed
sources said Portman was on the fence
about participating in the Thor sequel
because she wanted to spend more time
with her son who was only six months old
at the time the fact that jenkins
involvement and Thor the dark world
would make her the first woman to direct
such a big superhero film was what
convinced Portman to sign on thr sources
said once Jenkins was fired Portman was
livid with Marvel but contractually
obligated to continue whether or not the
story is true
publicly Portman has said she's open to
reprising her role as Jane Foster
talking to Screen Rant in early 2018 she
was asked about the possibility and said
I'm completely open to everything but I
have no news about that while 2017 s
thor ragnarok was unquestionably a hit
one event in the film left fans furious
when hella arrives on Asgard she
immediately murders two of the famous
warriors three Volstagg and Fandral
hogan the grim at least gets a few lines
of dialogue and a bit of a tussle with
hell up of where she kills him Kevin
Feige addressed the reason why Ray
Stevenson Zachary Levi and tada Nobu
Asano won't be seen again in the MCU
in a November 2017 junket press
conference
Feige said the filmmakers wanted to make
sure the audience saw hella as a real
threat he explained the Warriors three
had noble lands mainly to serve the
arrival of hella the following month at
the heroes and villains fan fest in San
Jose California
Levi admitted to fans that he was
disappointed not only with leaving the
MCU
but that band rules final words were
left on the cutting room floor according
to Lee by the way the scene was
originally shot the swashbuckling ladies
man charged hella crying for Asgard
before
dying while the red skull does appear in
Avengers infinity war that wasn't
actually Hugo Weaving under all those
prosthetics it was The Walking Dead's
Ross Marquand who replaced we beam for
the third Avengers film while weaving
had signed a multi pitcher deal with
Marvel Studios he decided he didn't want
to return after Captain America the
First Avenger and told Collider he
wasn't concerned about Marvel muscling
him into fulfilling his contract he said
I would be obliged to if they forced me
to but they wouldn't want to force
someone to do it if they didn't want to
unlike Terrence Howard and Natalie
Portman there aren't any reports of we
being harboring any harsh feelings
toward Marvel rather he simply wanted to
turn his attention away from
blockbusters weaving told Collider I
think I've done my - with that sort of
film it was good to do it and try it out
but to be honest it's not the sort of
film I seek out and I'm excited by for a
long time after Captain America the
First Avenger
the only blockbuster films weaving had
been a part of was his return as Elrond
in the first and third Hobbit movies and
even in those films his screen time was
relatively short while you'd be
hard-pressed to find many fans
complaining about Josh Brolin's casting
Estados he wasn't actually the first
actor to play the mad Titan Brolin first
played Thanos in 2014's guardians of the
galaxy but it wasn't Brolin giving us
that sinister profile in the mid credit
scene of the Avengers that was Damian
Poitier best known as du Prez in HBO's
True Blood plot er told geeks worldwide
that he didn't know he'd been cast as
Thanos until he was sitting in the
makeup chair he said I thought I was
clerked I thought it was going to be
super Skrull because the whole rumor was
that the scrolls were going to be in
Avengers no reports suggest that Marvel
was in any way unhappy with Poitier's
performance more likely it wasn't a
question of poitiers air being the wrong
choice but AB Rowland being so right
Kevin Feige has told Collider you look
at Rowland's face in the performance he
gives he could be Thanos without any
effects he has that kind of face and
that kind of gravitas to it though he
never reprised his role as Thanos the
Avengers was at Poitier's last
appearance in the MCU he also had a
small speaking role in Captain America's
Civil War as one of crossbones as
henchmen drew bit
or out of this trouble
[Music]
sadly Aaron taylor-johnson squick silver
didn't survive 2015's Avengers age of
Ultron he didn't see that coming
[Music]
his death came as a surprise to many
fans who were quick to speculate that
the motivation to kill the character had
something to do with Evan Peters being
introduced as Quicksilver in the
previous year's x-men Days of Future
past long before Disney acquired Fox
speaking to MTV in May 2015
Kevin Feige said Fox's Quicksilver had
nothing to do with the decision he said
quicksilver's death adds stakes to the
ending of the film to show repercussions
to Ultron's actions and also in a way to
solidify scarlet witch's character and
Wanda's arc in the movie and where we'll
see her in the next films
Feige went on to say Quicksilver died in
every draft of the script in 2016 while
promoting another movie taylor-johnson
echoed Feige and said age of Ultron
writer director Joss Whedon was lolling
the audience into a false sense of
security and playing with the widespread
fan believe that it would be Hawkeye who
didn't survive the film but Taylor
Johnson had a slightly different story
to tell while talking to cinema blend in
2015 while he did say the plan was
always for Quicksilver to die he also
admitted there was a costume designed
for him if his character were to survive
and that it was in his words really cool
oh well
nobody would know
nobody check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the MCU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]